XCOM is a game that is loved by many
including myself it is by far one of my
favorite games ever made so when I see a
game has a kind of a similar gameplay
that ex car has I always get excited so
today I'll be giving you my first
impressions on attack of the Earthlings
it's developed by team junk fish and
published by junk fish limited I'm
playing this on the xbox one s so
without any further ado let's go ahead
and get on with the first impression
attack on the Earthlings has a lot stuff
going for it and a lot of stuff holding
it back the game starts you off is
controlling a queen alien that is
attacking an earth settlement I'm not
gonna lie to you guys
this game starts out extremely slow and
the game takes the first couple levels
explaining to you exactly how this game
works and what kind of gameplay
mechanics you would expect to see
however when the game opens up and you
find out exactly what all you can do
with the alien that you have control
over the game actually gets quite
interesting now the Queen has a few
different abilities that make the game
extremely unique and fun she can create
a spawn in exchange for a kind of a
currency called biomass and that's the
material that you get from eating up any
type of dead ally or enemy in the game
she can also mind-control civilians that
you know that are wandering around the
map that you can actually use them to
scout the area and the only time that
the enemy would attack these is that
they're already with someone I'm looking
for they're already on the alert so what
happens is they'll be on the alert when
they're read when the their site becomes
red and if their sites green that means
that they're not really on alert for
anything and you haven't done in to
anything to make that unit hostile to
want to look around the area
now the spawns actually have some unique
abilities as well they can actually use
the same biomass that they were created
from to evolve to stronger versions of
themselves you have three different
versions you can either transform into a
tank that can reduce damage depending on
how much damage it takes or you can go
ahead and make a range fighter that can
shoot multiple tiles away so I really
enjoy that and then the third one is
kind of like you know a quick attacking
assail yet that actually can pierce
through armed
the unique thing about this is they all
have different strategic values on the
battlefield for instance there's certain
units that have a lot of health that you
can hit them with the big bulky tank and
it does more damage but there's some
units that don't necessarily have a
whole lot of health but they have a lot
of armor so you have two tackling the
unit that can actually do piercing
damage and there's some units that
actually do you know an AoE attack when
they die so you want to shoot them with
that ranged ability unit so you won't
actually take the damage of him so that
unit won't die one thing I really
enjoyed about this game is the
environment that's in it there are vents
in this game that you can't take with
every unit but you can take with some of
the unit's you could take it with the
initial spawn that the Queen makes and
you could take it with the armor
piercing spawn that you can upgrade it
to now the tank in the long range alien
spawn upgrade they can't go in these
vents and the reason these vents are
really useful is because there's certain
optional abilities that you have to do
during these missions and the only way
to really get these done is you have to
actually use these vents to get to that
certain area of the game you have to get
to them quick because you only have a
certain amount of time to do some of
these optional events another thing I
really enjoy about this game so far is
it's very non forgiving if you go to a
certain scenario that you didn't really
anticipate too much or you take a one of
the spawns into a vent you can easily
get that character die just by walking
into a door that you didn't really scout
too much and these kind of games I feel
like sometimes they make these
particular games a little bit too easy
and too forgiving so I liked and really
enjoyed the fact that you know you have
to really really pay attention to your
surroundings and exactly where you're
going and another good thing is the
Queen alien her spawn and her three
upgrades actually have a unique tree for
every one of them so you can use these
trees to upgrade them to the power that
they would necessarily need a bee to
continue the game now in terms of
content I don't know if there's anything
more than the seven missions that has
laid out to you in the map I would
assume that if the last mission isn't
the last mission there might be one more
after that I would be very surprised if
there's another one of these little
established
after you beat this one now let's talk
about graphics is this it's nothing
special but for the cost of the game I
don't have an issue with that at all in
terms of replayability I don't really
see me playing this game again after I
beat it because I don't really see the
change of gameplay being changed from
playing it again so I don't think
there's a whole lot of replayability now
if you really enjoy this genre like I do
maybe I can go back and play through it
and you know get the achievements and
stuff like that I'd like to personally
thank teen junk fish for sending me this
it was a unique experience that I
actually really enjoyed the one thing I
do want to say is this game is for the
Nintendo switch and I believe that it's
worth the price tag that they give on it
I put about 13 hours and still have a
few levels left and if you enjoyed this
impressions that I did you can always
catch my opinion every Sunday at 1 p.m.
Eastern where me and the other Lords we
break down all sorts of events all sorts
of topics definitely come by there it's
on the iron Lords podcast channel
assuming you're watching it on here
anyway so definitely hit that subscribe
button if you want more of my opinion
like the video if you don't mind it's
been a pleasure playing this game once
again I want to thank team junk fish
this is gay this is Lord addict I'm out
of your peace